five of the Democrats running for
president will have to leave the
campaign trail to be jurors in the
upcoming Senate impeachment trial now
this is a very tricky time the Iowa
caucuses are just three weeks away from
today yet o'keefe is in Washington with
more on this story boy talk about bad
timing for the Senators what are they
planning to do well good morning Gail
the five senators all say they'll be in
Washington for the trials to fulfill
their constitutional duties but they
might sneak out of town during breaks to
try to meet with voters Bernie Sanders
and Amy Klobuchar are say they might
charter jets from DC to Iowa and New
Hampshire for nighttime rallies that
will get them back to DC in the same
night Elizabeth Warren and Klobuchar are
also planned to deploy their husbands
while Sanders is expected to send out
supporters like congresswoman Alexandra
Ocasio Cortes to seek out support
meanwhile a new Iowa poll out over the
weekend shows the race remains unsettled
Sanders is on top followed by Warren
former South Bend Indiana mayor Pete
Buddha judge and former Vice President
Joe Biden so so at Bernie Sanders we
just see has a lead in Iowa but we also
heard that he's kicking up the attacks
on his rivals what's he saying
that's right his campaign over the
weekend Yael once again criticized
Biden's support for the Iraq war but
Sanders denied that he approved a script
instructing his volunteers to criticize
Warren CBS News has an independently
verified a script obtained by Politico
that reportedly instructs volunteers to
tell voters that Warren only appeals to
quote highly educated more affluent
people and that she won't be able to
expand the base of the Democratic Party
Warren responded on Sunday I was
disappointed to hear that Bernie is
sending his volunteers out to trash me
Bernie knows me and has known me for a
long time we all saw the impact of the
factionalism in 2016 and we can't have a
repeat of that Democrats need to unite
our party Warren doubled down on a
response last night by sending out a
fundraising email that called out
Sanders as a tax Gail it's cold in Iowa
this morning but the campaign is heating
up it's ever-changing thank you very
much ed O'Keefe will talk to you a
little bit later on
you